bueno buenas tardes gracias por la
invitación desde la fundación paz y
reconciliación
vemos este asunto como un hito en
los logros realizados por la
jurisdicción especial para la paz de
llevar a un conjunto de 11 militares a
compensar digamos todo lo que habían
hecho en el marco de la guerra y como en
digamos en durante el gobierno uribe las
presiones militares y de gobierno hacían
que la eficacia de las fuerzas militares
se midieran con bajas en combate y no a
través por ejemplo de operaciones
efectivas donde se garantizará la vida
de las personas de las poblaciones
etcétera es un hito en el marco del
sistema integral de verdad justicia
reparación y no reparar y no repetición
es sumamente importante también como
medida de reparación de verdad ante las
víctimas que tuvieron una participación
en ese escenario de confesión y que
también hablaron
un conjunto de mujeres empobrecidas
que sus familiares fueron digamos
presentados y legítimamente como
guerrilleros caídos en combate tuvieron
la posibilidad de contarle al país que
sus hijos que sus familiares no eran
guerrilleros como las fuerzas militares
habían presentado y también veces una
medida digamos que permite reparar un
poco esa injusticia cometida
especialmente con mayor intensidad
durante la primera década del siglo 21
en el marco del gobierno de álvaro uribe
bits digo la violencia contra los
líderes civiles no se detiene en
colombia la defensoría del pueblo del
país denunció que estos tres primeros
meses de 2002 asesinaron a al menos 52
quienes estarían detrás de estos hechos
y qué está haciendo el estado colombiano
al respecto
bueno digamos con esta declaración de la
defensoría del pueblo se confirma que
hay una continuidad en las violencias en
contra de personas líderes y defensoras
de derechos humanos y los líderes más
afectados por esta violencia son líderes
comunales líderes campesinos
afrodescendientes e indígenas y lo que
estamos evidenciando también digamos
desde el inicio del gobierno del bando
que en el 2018 es un aumento de las
tensiones armadas y del conflicto de las
confrontaciones en distintos lugares del
país que fueron los más afectados por la
violencia de la guerra los principales
autores presuntamente responsables de
estas violencias no están identificados
en su mayoría pero los que sí están
identificados son el clan del golfo la
estructura criminal más grande del país
sucesora del paramilitarismo
y las llamadas disidencias de las farc y
del resto digamos serían acciones de a
través de sicariato que no estarían
necesariamente vinculadas o esclarecidas
que hay una vinculación con
organizaciones criminales entonces este
es el panorama nos preocupa mucho que
desde el año 2016 firma el acuerdo de
paz a este año hay 16 casos en los
cuales la fuerza pública tendría alguna
participación en esta victimización
presuntamente desde el tema de la
fiscalía y que se está haciendo del
estado vemos que no hay una gran
claridad en materia de valga la
redundancia esclarecimiento de los casos
en materia judicial de los presuntos
perpetradores o de los autores
intelectuales sino que se habla
específicamente en algunos casos muy
reducidos de autores materiales entonces
no se llega al fondo de la circunstancia
del asesinato y de distintos tipos de
victimización en contra de personas
defensoras de derechos humanos
colombia es el país más violento para
defensores y defensoras de derechos
humanos en el mundo en el año 2020
tuvimos 223 líderes y lideresas sociales
asesinados a lo largo del país entonces
este es un drama que va en aumento y
para lo cual ni el gobierno nacional ni
la fiscalía se han comprometido en el
esclarecimiento de los procesos
judiciales lleva alejandro restrepo
muchísimas gracias por esta minuto con
france24